RESPONSE TO THE CODE NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MAY NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE%
ACCESS. THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WAS SENATOR HENRY STERN
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY SENATOR
STERN IF YOU HAVE SUPPORT STAFF
WITH YOU CAN YOU PLEASE
IDENTIFY THEM NOW. YES A
SENATOR MISTER AND I DID OFFICE
AND I'M HERE WOULD YOU WILL
DISTRICT ARE. THANK YOU STERN.
SENATOR STERN AS A REMINDER
PLEASE ME YOUR PHONE CA THIS
GREAT AID ANY FEEDBACK I GUESS
IT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO
RECOGNIZE THAT YOU WILL RAISE
THE USE THAT HAND REYES
FEATURE- IN THE PROGRAM EACH
TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO ON MUTE PLEASE SELECT
ON MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING ARE IT PERSONNEL WILL
PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE. WHEN
YOU'RE DONE ONCE RECOGNIZE THE
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN
BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE
YOUR NAME. AND THEN YOU'RE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS
WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
OR IS FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WISH TESTIFIED THAT. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED. ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS FIVE SIX FOUR. SIX NINE
FOUR SIX. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU'LL BE WAIT YOU
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON MUTE IT AND YOU WILL AND YOU
ARE NOW TO WOULD THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING. THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE IS IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM
YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS. MUTED WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
IN OUR CONDUCT. AN A CONDUCTOR
HEARINGS. IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME
SCRIPT HAS BEEN SOARED JUST
INTO THE NEW USE. ONLINE TOOLS
AND TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENTS WITH
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. TODAY WE HAVE SEVEN
BILLS ON THE AGENDA BUT THREE
OF THOSE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION THE BILL'S LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. MR
CONSULTING WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. NUMBER HERE
NUMBER. NIELSEN NIELSEN HERE
HERTZBERG. LEYVA HERE LEYVA
HERE STERN DURING THEIR STAY
HERE WE HAVE A CORE Q. TODAY WE
HAVE THREE BILLS ON CONSENT
CALENDAR WE EMOTION THE CONSENT.
SOME OF. CENTER LEYVA MOVES THE
CONSENT CALENDAR- MR CONSOLE
WHICH PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR NUMBER HI
NUMBER I NIELSEN ALL I NIELSEN
I. HERTZBERG LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE STERN. STERN HI THANK YOU
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN- FOR
CENTER HERTZBERG TO DISSIPATE
NEXT WE HAVE A. B. SIX FOUR SIX
BY SOME OF THE MORE MCCARTY I
UNDERSTAND SENATOR HURTS FOR IS
GOING TO PRESENT EIGHTY SIX
FORCE. NOT I DON'T SEE CENTER
HURTS. LET'S SEE. AND WE CAN'T
LET ME ASK A TECHNICAL QUESTION
IF THE PERSON PRESENTING IS NOT
HERE CAN WE MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
BUILDERS THAT CREATIVE BUT
TECHNOLOGY ISSUE. WELL NEXT WE
WOULD GO TO AB ONE TWO SEVEN
SIX BUT MR BONTA I WOULD BE
PRESENTING THAT AS A MATTER OF
FACT. SO WHICH IS IT WE COULD
GO TO AB ONE TWO SEVEN SIX.
OKAY WELL LET US DO THAT- I
WILL VACATE. THE ROSTRUM I'M
GONNA S. CENTER NIELSEN. IF HE
WOULD. IF YOU WOULD PRESIDE.
HEY CENTER ARE YOU PREPARED TO
BEGIN 2% YOUR AB TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX WHICH YOU WILL BE CARING
FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA TODAY
YES I AM THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- THANK YOU CHAIR AND
SANDERS I'M PRESENTING AB
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX SOMEBODY
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER. MEMBER
BONTA. TWELVE SEVENTY SIX AS A
FOLLOW UP TO A. B. EIGHT FOUR
NINE THE FAIR MAPS ACT THAT WAS
SUPPORTED BY THIS COMMITTEE
LAST YEAR. THROUGH THE FAIR
MAPS ACT ABLE TO GRANT.
DISENFRANCHISES COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN LEFT OUT OF OUR
DEMOCRACY A FIGHTING CHANCE THE
ADVOCATING FOR THEMSELVES IN
KEEPING THE COMMUNITIES HOLD
DURING THAT REDISTRICTING
PROCESS. AB TWELVE SEVENTY SIX
MAKES CLARIFYING CHANGES TO THE
FAIR MAPS ACT ADDS BACK
NEGOTIATE LANGUAGE. THAT AS
INADVERTENTLY DELETED DURING
THE DRAFTING OF AB EIGHT FOUR
NINETY CLARIFIES EXISTING LAW
IN OUR CHARTER CITIES. IT ALSO
FIXES ISSUES IN THE TIMELINE
FOR LOCAL REDISTRICTING AN
ADVERT WE CREATED BY A. B.
EIGHT FOUR NINE AND MAKE
SPECIFIC TIMELINE ADJUSTMENTS
FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
ACCOMMODATE. THE ANTICIPATED
DELAY IN THE RELEASE OF CENSUS
DATA. AB TWELVE SEVENTY SIX
ADJUST THE MAP ADOPTION
DEADLINE TO ENSURE THAT OCAL
MAPS ADOPTED BEFORE THE
SIGNATURE IN LIEU. OF FILING
FEE PROCESS BEGINS AS SPECIFIED
IN ELECTIONS COUNTER. CURRENT
STATE LAW REQUIRES OF MAPS BE
ADOPTED ONE HUNDRED FIFTY ONE
DAYS BEFORE THE- FIRST
SELECTION WHICH THEY WOULD BE
USE THE DEADLINE IS MOVED. TO
LEARN FIVE BEFORE SELECT.
DESPITE TO BE RESULT ENSURING
THAT THE MAP WILL BE IN BEFORE
THE SIGNATURE IN LIEU OF. FEE
BEGINS ONE SEVENTY DAYS BE THE-
EVEN MORE SIGNIFICANTLY TWELVE
SEVENTY SIX MAKES NESS ONE IT
JUST TO THE MAY. ABOUT PERIOD
AND TWENTY ONE COME THE- SENSES
TO. FOR JOE. LITTLE TAKING
PLACE ON OR BEFORE THE
ANTICIPATE STATE WHY PRIMARY
ELECTION OF JUNE SEVENTH.
TWENTY TWO TWO KHRISTICH MOST
OF MATT ON SEVENTY FOUR DAYS
FOR THEIR ELECTION LOCAL
STATIONS EXTRA. THE
REDISTRICTING. AB TWELVE SIX AS
MANY CHIU. BUT EVERY ADDITION
WEEK EL TO THE PROVIDE HIM INTO
THE ADDRESS CROSS OF PROGRESS.
FOR THE WHO HAVE BEEN. THE FOR
THESE OF SOME OF OUR BOND. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR VOTE. ON
THE PHONE PROVIDE. ON AB TWELVE
SEMI SIX IS JULIA MARK STAFF
ATTORNEY FOR THE VOTING RIGHTS
AND SENSES PROGRAM. THAT ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE. OF
THE ASIAN LAW CAUCUS CO IN THE
ASIAN LAW CAUCUS CO SPONSORS
THE BILL I ALSO HAVE A-
NECKLACE. HEY NORM FROM COMMON
CAUSE ALSO CUT CLOSE SPONSORS
BILL ONLINE PRETTY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS PERTAINING TO AB
EIGHT FOUR NINE FROM LAST YEAR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. MS MARK
SERVER REPRESENTING ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
ASIAN LAW CAUCUS WOULD NEW OR
ARE YOU PREPARED TO PROCEED
WITH YOUR TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS LEGISLATION. YES I AM
OKAY PLEASE THANK HERE CHAIR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CHAIR ON
BURKE IN SENATOR AB TALKED OF.
SIX IF THE CALL IT BUILT LAST
YEAR'S AB EIGHT FOUR NINE FIVE
MEMBER. WHICH ALLOWED FOR REAL
BUT PUBLIC IN. INTO LOCAL READ
AND CAL. THE BILL ESTABLISH
UNIFORM REDUCE CRITERIA
DEADLINE AND THE CENTRAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR CITY COUNTY.
INCLUDING WHAT PART SO HOLE FR
HEARINGS WORKSHOP TOGETHER
COMMUNITY PART. ELECTION IN
WHICH THE MAPS ARE YOU. RIGHT I
WANT A ONE MONTH BUFFER BETWEEN
NAPA ADOPTION AND THE START OF
THE IN LIEU SIGNATURE
COLLECTION KERRY AND IN CASE
THAT BLOCK WOULD DISPUTE THAT
REQUIRES COURT INVOLVEMENT IT
ALSO PROVIDES SIX AND A HALF
MONTHS FOR CANADA NOW AND
CAMPAIGN I NEED TO START.
SECOND BECAUSE OF THE POSSIBLE
DELAY IN THE RELEASE OF THE
DATA IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE
HAVE AMENDED AB TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX INCLUDE A PROVISION
EXTENDING THE MAP AND OPTIONS
THAT MINE IN TWENTY. KLAY
REDISTRICTING DATA ARE RELEASED
BY IT FIRST OF THE YEAR
FOLLOWING. FOR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE INDICATED THAT THE DATA MAY
BE REALLY AREN'T AS LATE AS
AUGUST FIRST. ZERO CONTINUES TO
CHANGE TIMELINE IF YOU TALK TO
ME THANK PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY
THAT WILL ALLOW LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THE PLAN FOR
ADEQUATE PUBLIC INPUT AND IT
GOT ME TO. FOR JURISDICTIONS
THAT HAVE AN ELECTION BEFORE
JULY TWENTY TWENTY TWO AB TALK
ANYTHING WOULD REQUIRE THAT
FINAL MAP BE ADOPTED AT LEAST A
HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR DAYS
BEFORE THE NEXT ELECTION.
SHOULD BE JURISDICTION BUT IN
LIEU CARRIER IN THE REQUISITE
NUMBER SIGNATURE MAY ALSO BE
PROPORTIONALLY SHORTENED.
MAINTAIN ABOUT FOR. AB
COMPANIES ALSO CORRECT THE
MINOR DRAFTING ERROR. IN AB
EIGHT FOUR NINE AND MAKES OTHER
MOSTLY TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING
CHANGES. SUCH AS CLARIFYING BUT
CHARTERS IT CAN ADOPT
INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION. AMENDMENTS ARE
SUPPORTED BY A BROAD COALITION
OF CIVIL RIGHTS AND GOOD
GOVERNMENT GROUPS FROM AROUND
CALIFORNIA AND HAVE BEEN VETTED
WITH THE LEAGUE OF CITY AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES I DO NOT OBJECT TO THE
CHANGES. HAPPENING A. B. TWELVE.
IT'S NOT VERY TO ADDRESS THE
LIKELY DELAY IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AT THE DATA. IN JULY AND
THE REDISTRICTING DEADLINE WELL
ACTION CALENDAR. WE THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR CARRYING WITH
RECORDING QUALIFIED YOUR
QUESTION TO CREATE A FAIR AND-
WE DISTRICT. AND WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE I. THANK YOU. YOU AND
SENATOR THAT NUMBER DO YOU WISH
FOR MR NECKLACE HI ADORNED TO
TESTIFY OR IS HE THERE TO
RESPONSIBLY TO QUESTION HE'S
HE'S HE'S HERE TO ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS SHOULD
THERE BE ANY OKAY THAT'S FINE
WE WILL THEN PROCEED. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER SUPPORT WITNESSES
HERE IN THE CHAMBER. THE DESIRE
TO TESTIFY. SHOWING NON. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES THAT ARE
SITTING IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
THAT WISH TO TESTIFY FOR TWELVE
SEVENTY SIX TODAY. ANYONE IN.
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX TWENTY FORTY
TO SUPPORT. TWELVE SEVENTY SIX.
SHARING NON. THEN WE WILL
PROCEED. TO THE
TELECONFERENCING. TO THE
MODERATOR. IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
CALLING IN. GIVE US AN
ASSESSMENT OF THE NUMBERS. AND
THEN INTRODUCE THEM TO US. AND
WE WOULD BEGIN THE TESTIMONY OF
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX MODERATOR. SHARE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
NOW. AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD NOW. WE HAVE
ABOUT SIX THANK YOU. WELL FIRST
GOTO LINE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI EVERYONE THIS IS
SAMUEL MOLINA CALIFORNIA STATE
DIRECTOR OF MISSION LEGAL COSTS
IN FULL SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL PAUL SEVEN SIX. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL WITNESS. PLEASE
PROCEED. UP NEXT LEVEL CAROLINE
FIFTY SIX WE'VE GOT HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON HEARING MEMBER
MELISSA ROMERO AT THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
OF AB TALK. THANK YOU. AND THAT
THE LAW TO LINE FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
ME OF USING YOUR THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS CALLING IN THE
PORT I'VE ALSO BEEN AUTHORIZED
TO CONVEY THAT THE CORE OF
CALIFORNIA COMMON QUALITY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND THAT
THE LOCAL LINE FIFTY THREE
YEARS AGO I HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
NO OUTWARD ON BEHALF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX. VERY WELL.
AND I. LOVE ALL THE TIME
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE GAYLE
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER IN
SUPPORT OF. THANK YOU. AND THAT
THE LAW TO LINE SIX I AM
PLEASED WELL I HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS THE JANUARY
ARE WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES- THE LEAGUE
IS NEUTRAL ON THE MEASURE BUT
WOULD LIKE TO CONVEY OUR OUR
GRATITUDE FOR THE STAKEHOLDERS
FOR THEIR COLLABORATIVE PROCESS
IN GETTING THE MEASURE TO THIS
POINT. THANK YOU. THANK VERY
MINDER TO SHOW SUPPORTPLEASE
PRESS THE LAW AND THEN ZERO NOW
AGAIN LONDON ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE TO MAKE YOU. THE MODERATE
WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
AND THEN. TO ANYONE WHO WISHES
TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION. TO AB.
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX. AND NOW
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO UPHOLD PLEASE PRESS ONE
WITHIN THEIR OWN NOW. AGAIN TO
OPPOSE PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN
THEIR OWN NOW. AND THERE'S NO
ONE IN THE QUEUE. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE SENATE CHAMBERS.
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE WE WILL
GO TO TWENTY FORTY. AND TAT
ROOM APPEARS TO BE EMPTY IS
THERE ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE THEN. MODERATOR THAT WOULD
EXHAUST ALL INDIVIDUALS AND WHO
WERE WILLING AND DESIROUS OF
TESTIFYING AT ALL TODAY CORRECT.
THAT IS CORRECT THANK YOU.
LET'S NOW. WITH THE TESTIMONY
COMPLETE. ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ONE OF THE BILL.
PARDON YES MOVE THE BILL MOVE
THE BILL. OKAY CENTER DAVID HAS
MOVED THE BILL. DO YOU WISH TO
HAVE ANYTHING THIS DISCUSS ON
THAT MOTION CENTER LEYVA. NO NO
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR UMBERG
WOULD YOU LIKE TO GIVE US YOUR
CLOSING COMMENTS YES UP I URGE
AN AYE.VOTE THANK YOU OR IS AN
AYE VOTE. ON AB TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX AB TWELVE SEVENTY SIX THE
MOTION IS DO PASS COME BURKE
NUMBER I NIELSEN. NO NIELSEN NO
HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT HERTZBERG
HI LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE STERN.
STERN ONLY BILLS OUT FOR TWO
ONE THE BILL HAS PASSED. FOR
TWO ONE. GENDER I WILL YIELD TO
YOU AGAIN.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SENATOR NIELSEN NEXT UP IS AB
SIX FOUR SIX TO BE PRESENTED BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG CENTER
HERTZBERG BE PREPARED I AM
INDEED. ALL RIGHT. SERVERS YOU
MAY PROCEED. I'LL BE FOR ME.
ONE SECOND I GOTTA GIVE IT IN
MISSION HERE. THIS IS A CENTER
ARTS FOR GO HEAD PRESENT ALL
READ THE ADMISSION AFTER YOU DO
YOUR PRESENTATION THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB SIX FORTY
SIX. BY ASSEMBLYMAN MCCARTY
THINK GIVEN THESE NEW A SHOWER
CAPS WE'VE GOT I THINK I'LL GET
A MATCHING SHARK TO. EQUAL WE
HAVE HERE IN OUR MICROPHONES IN
MY LOOK. FETCHING TURMAN. THIS
HOUSE AND THE OTHER HOUSE
PASSED ACA'S SIX CURRENTLY ON
THE BALLOT QUALIFIED AT AS ON
THE BALLOT FOR THE VOTERS TO
VOTED IN NOVEMBER BY MEASURE IS
A COMPANION BILL THROUGH THE
ACA SET IT UPDATES RELEVANT
CALIFORNIA ELECTION CODE
SECTIONS TO REFLECT CHANGES IN
OUR ELIGIBILITY SHOULD PROP
SEVENTY WHICH IS A CA SIX
PASSES THIS NOVEMBER IT
CLARIFIES THAT INDIVIDUAL ON
PAROLE OF THE RIGHT TO PRE.
REGISTER AN VOTE I SHOULD.
BECAUSE OUR TODAY- CHRISTIAN
ETHIC SAYS THAT WHEN YOU PAY
YOUR DEBT TO SOCIETY YOUR DEBT
IS PAID WE TAKE THESE FOLKS AND
WE CONTINUALLY OSTRACIZE THEM
FROM ANY LEVEL OF CITIZENSHIP
AND OF WHICH VOTING IS AT THE
CORE OF WHAT THAT IS AND SO I
STRONGLY STAND IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE AND ASK THIS
COMMITTEE TO. THIS MEASURE UP
TODAY YES MY WITNESSES SUPPORT.
IS A VOTING RIGHTS LAWYER THE
ACLU BRITNEY STONE'S FIRE.
BRITNEY. BEFORE WE TURN TO WIN
ISN'T SUPPORT DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. YOURS MEANS TO TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY THERE FOR
EACH PERMITTED PERMITTED THREE
MINUTES ALL THE QUESTION
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR CAR TO
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURE. SO AS
YOU'D ANNOUNCED I BELIEVE YOUR
WITNESS IS BRITNEY- STONES FOR
STONE FOR STONE'S FOR BOB AND
MISSED ON SIR- WITH THESE SO
YOU ARE YOU ON THE LINE NOW
MATT A MODERATOR IF YOU'D-
CONNECT YES MA'AM. JOHN SIR AND
TWENTY YES HI. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS BRITTANY DUMP MY FOR
AND ANOTHER GREAT ATTORNEY WITH
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA AND A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT- COALITION
AS SENATOR HERTZBERG EXPLAINED
AB SIX FORTY SIX FOR THE
COMPANION THX WHICH IS NOW
KNOWN AS PROPS. IN THE NEXT
FORTY SIX ARE GOING TO LOOK
BACK ONLY AT. MORE THAN FIFTY
OF VOTERS PASSED SEVENTEEN IN
NOVEMBER. SEVENTEEN OVER STORE
RIGHT TO PEOPLE ON PAROLE
IMMEDIATELY UPON COMPLETION OF
THAT PRISON TERM. CHANGE WITH
BRING CALIFORNIA IN LINE WITH
NINETEEN OTHER STATES AND THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA PUBLIC
WHICH EITHER ALLOW ELIGIBLE
PEOPLE THAT THOSE PENSION IF
THEY RELEASED FROM PRISON. OR
THEY HAVE NO FELONY
DISENFRANCHISEMENT. BOB PROCTOR
LOOKING WITHIN THE LEGISLATURE
AS EASY A SEX AT PASSED BOTH
THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY IT WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FROM AT
LEAST TWO THIRDS OF THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF EACH OF
THOSE HOUSES. AGAIN THE MEASURE
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY
ASSEMBLY A TECHNICAL CLEAN UP
THEY'LL THAT WILL CONFORM.
SECTIONS OF THE STATE ELECTION
CODE. IN YOUR AND SEVENTEEN AT
THIS NOVEMBER. YEAH PROP
SEVENTEEN AND. SIX FORTY ON THE
TO MARKET THE SPARE AND MARK.
AND AB FORTY SIX ON THE OUR
LECTURE CLOCK LOGICALLY MORE
WORKABLE ABOUT THE- AND VOTERS
FOR THESE REASONS. ASK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER MISTER-
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
HERE IN THE CHAMBER WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY SEEING NONE LET'S
RETURN TO A ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING NONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY OF MATTER MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANY ON THE PHONE WHO WISH
TO. TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF. AB
SIX FOUR SIX. AND MY AND ON
THEM. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE DIDN'T THEIR
OWN NOW. IN THE SHOW IF THE
COURT PLEASE PRESS ONE TO IN
THEIR OWN NOW. ALEX LIKE WE DO
HAVE THAT CAN MAKE YOU LOCAL TO
LINE NUMBER FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO TERRY MEMBERS
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
OF AB SIX FORTY SIX. THANK YOU.
HELLO CAROLINE NUMBER FIFTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO ME
OF USING YOUR FROM THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
FOUR SIX THANK YOU. AND THAT
THE WHOLE TIME SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE CALL I HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CRYSTAL GET OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
SUPPORT THANK YOU. CAN I GET A
LOT TO LINE SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE CALL I HAD. REBECCA
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. IF YOU. AND
THAT THE LOCAL LINE SIXTY SIX
PLEASE CALL I HAD. I AM YOUR
MOLINA CALIFORNIA STATE
DIRECTOR OF THE FAMILY OF ALL
TIME- BURN FULL SUPPORT BABY
SIX FORTY SIX THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SO OF ALL TIME SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE CALL I HAD. I GET
AFTERNOON GREGORY SAID OUT
THERE SHE JUST THIS SPROUT CO
SPONSORS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE BEEN THEIR OWN NOW
AGAIN IT TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THAN THEIR OWN NOW.
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A ONE MORE
COMING INAND I'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE. AND THAT THE LAW
TIMELINE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
CALL I HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS GERMAN BURKE ON BEHALF OF A
FRIEND COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
THE CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAD NO
MORE AND MAKE YOU. THANK YOU-
NOW TURNED OPPOSITION. MADAM
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
IN OPPOSITION TO A. B. SIX FOUR
SIX. AND GENTLEMEN A FIELD.
PLEASE PRESS ONE WITHIN THEIR
OWN NOW BUT AGAIN TO UPHOLD
PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN ZERO NOW.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE.
ALL RIGHT I SEE NO ONE IN THE
CHAMBER WHO WHICH IS THE
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
SIX FOUR SIX LET'S LOOK AT ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE THERE IN A POSITION.
CITY NON I WILL BRING IT BACK%
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
OF MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. A
YES CENTER NIELSEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN IF I MAY TO THE
AUTHOR OR ANY OF THE SUPPORT
WITNESS. OF THE- THIS. THE
DEATH. DO MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
DOES THIS. RIGHT IS IT
TRIGGERED BY THE RELEASE FROM
CUSTODY. AND OR THE RELATION
CASH TO THE- AND THE DISTRAUGHT
FARMER FORMAL DISCHARGE FROM
PAROLE. HERTZBERG VIEW YEAH I
THINK I RESPOND OR HAVE A ONE
THE WITNESS IS RESPONDING TO
SEE FOR SECOND I THINK I HAVE
THE DEFINITION HERE I JUST
READ. MISTER WAY TO DO THIS.
BOB WELL I HAVE THE WITNESSES
BUT IN TERMS OF THE DEFINITION
I THINK YOU KNOW FROM YOUR
PREVIOUS WORK IMPRISONED OF
COURSE MEANS THE CURRENTLY
SERVICE STATE OR FEDERAL PRISON
SENTENCE PAROLE IS TO ME THE
TERM OF SUPERVISION BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION AND ED OF
FICTION WRITING JUVENILE ASIAN
MADE PURSUANT TO EXISTING LAW
SO I THINK THE ISSUE ABOUT IS
THERE STILL A TWO ROOM. TO THE
ACT. TEST BUT- THIS SAUCE FOR
OUR USE ON THE LINE. MATAMATA
WRITER IF THERE'S SOMEONE ON
THE LINE WHO WISHES TO RESPOND
IF YOU WOULD OPEN THEIR LINE.
ARE YOU ASKING IF BRITNEY ASKED
ON THE LINE SHE IS HE MAY BE
NEEDED ON HER AND- YEAH YEAH.
YES SO AT SENATOR HERTZBERG
DESCRIBED PEARL IS INTENDED TO
BE AT THE COMMUNITY YOU
PREVENTION- THE- THAT YOU KNOW
CO DESCRIBES THAT AS A PERIOD
RE ENTRY ABOUT THE CENTRAL
DEPOSIT CITIZENSHIP SO IT IS A
DISTINCTIVE. THAT HAPPENED
AFTER THE COMPLETION OF THE
PRINTER. BUT THANK YOU THE
NIELSEN TO THAT POINT THEN I
WILL DISPUTE I BELIEVE THAT THE
SENTENCE IMPOSED BY A JURY AND
THE COURT AND THE JUDGE IN THE
COURT. A IS NOT EXTINGUISHED
UNTIL SUCH TIME AS THERE IS A
FORMAL DISCHARGE. SIGN. SO I
THINK THERE'S A THERE'S AN
ERROR AND THEN JUSTICE HERE THE
VICTIMS IN SOCIETY. HAVE A
RIGHT. LEGAL RIGHTS TO BE
ASSURED THAT THE FULL JUST
SEARCH HAVE BEEN. AND IT'S TIME
SERVE. THAT'S ALL SEC THEY YOU
CENTER NIELSEN ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. ABOUT MOVE THE BILL
THERE LEYVA MOVES THE BILL. MR
CONSULTING WOULD YOU CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE. SB SIX FORTY SIX
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG BACK
NUMBER I NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO
HERTZBERG HI HERTZBERG BY LABOR
HI LEAVE A STERN. ALL RIGHT
STERN AYE STERN ON IN THE
BILL'S OUT FOUR TO ONE THANK
YOU AND- MISTER CONSULT WOULD
YOU GO AHEAD AND CALL OPEN THE
ROLE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR WE
HAVE A FULL COMPLEMENT OF
MEMBERS AT THIS POINT. ON THE
CONSENT COUNT. CURRENT VOTE IS
FOUR TO ZERO HERTZBERG HI
HERTZBERG AND CONSENT COUNTERS
OUT FIVE TWO ZERO. THANK YOU-
NEXT WE HAVE AB TWO FOUR ZERO
ZERO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK.
THE SEVEN MEMBER QUIRK HERE ARE
YOU SPUR ARE YOU PRESENTING ON
BEHALF OF SOME INDEED I AM IS
CONSIDER HERTZBERG QUITE
POPULAR TODAY. A SERVICE FOR
YOU PREPARED I AM INDEED ALL
RIGHT. PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-
INTRODUCED A. B. TWENTY ONE
TWENTY FIVE THIS MEASURE BUILDS
UPON THAT ON EFFORT BY THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BASICALLY IN
SIMPLE TERMS AFTER EACH
ELECTION APPROACH ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS ARE ARE TO COMPLETE
AN OFFICIAL CANVASS ARM VOTE
PROCESS NOTED IN THIRTY DAYS
AFTER THE BALLOT THE ELECT OF
COURSE WE ALL WE- ALL KNOW THAT.
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES ALL
OFFICIALS TO CONDUCT PUBLICLY
MANUALLY TALLY OF BALLOTS ED IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE PASSED
IN THE GOVERNOR SIGNED. THE
ASSEMBLY RECORDS MEASURE THAT
CREATED A PILOT PROGRAM WHICH
PERMITS COUNTIES TO CONDUCT A
RISK LIMITING AUDIT IN LIEU OF
ONE OF THE IN LIEU OF A- A
MANUAL TALLY. COUNTIES COULD
COULD THOSE AUDITS IN ADDITION.
TO THE 1% MANUAL. AS SET FORTH
IN AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY FIVE
FROM TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
WHICH INCLUDED STATISTICAL
EXPERTS. STAKEHOLDERS ELECTION
OFFICIALS IN THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE AT A DISCOVERED
THAT THIS IDEA OF A RISK
LIMITING AUDITS REACH ELECTION
COULD RESULT IN A FULL MANUAL
TOP OF THE ENTIRE RELUCTANT.
COUNTIES WISHING TO PARTICIPATE
IN ONE OF THESE RICH CLIPPING
AUDITS. COULDN'T DO SO WITHOUT
BY THE LIKELY OF. ALL OF ALL
BALLOTS WHICH COMPLETELY VOIDED
THE PURPOSE OF TWENTY ONE FORTY
FIVE SO THE SOLUTION HERE THIS
MEASURE TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED. IT
INCENTIVIZE IS COUNTIES TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE RISK
LIMITING AUDIT PROGRAM BY
REMOVING THE ALL OR NOTHING
REQUIREMENT BERRIER. THIS
MEASURE CLARIFIES PERMIT IT
PERMITS CARRIES CAN COUNT IN
LIEU OF END OR IN ADDITION TO
THE 1% MANUAL TALLY. ON ANY
AMOUNT OF ELECTION RESULTS FIVE
FOR THAT I ASK YOU FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND WE HAVE TIFFANY YOU
MARK FOR THIS CALIFORNIA
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE AS
THE WITNESS IN THIS MATTER
THANK YOU THANK YOU I THINK
FOLKS REMEMBER MY ADMONITION
FROM BEFORE BUT BECAUSE OF. THE
KOBE CRISIS WE'RE GOING TO.
ENTERTAIN TEST MOBILE
TELEPHONICALLY AND FROM THE
CHAMBER BOTH IN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FALLOUT THREE
MINUTES STREET SIDE. ALL RIGHT-
MISS MARK ARE YOU ON THE PHONE.
I AM A ARE I AND IT MISS
MARKETED LIKE PERCENT MILITARY.
SURE NUMBER THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME THE MOCK ON
BEHALF OF SECRETARY STATE HOW
EXPEDIA AND SENATOR HERTZBERG
NOTED. PLEASE I'M SURE THAT
BELL WITCH HAS ALREADY BEEN
DESCRIBED FOR EVERYTHING THAT I
CAN'T BE. BETTER EXPLAINING
THAT OFFERS REASONS WE ORDER
AYE VOTE AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU OTHERS OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE IN
CHAMBER- ROOM TWENTY FORTY. NO
ONE IN TWENTY FORTY- OTHERS ON
THE PHONE WHICH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION.
AND THAT YOU SUPPORT. CHAIRAND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS THE WIND IN THEIR OWN NOW.
AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW. WE
HAVE ONE PERSON LOCAL TOW LINE
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO I HAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON KEREN MEMBERS
TRICIA WEBER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF QUIRK AND
ELECTION OFFICIALS THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FOUR HUNDRED. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHERS AND AS A REMINDER IF YOU
WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN FERAL AGAIN ONE
THEN ZERO TO CHILL SUPPORT NOW.
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE. ALL RIGHT IN OPPOSITION
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
ANYONE OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE.
IF YOU WERE A COUPLE PLEASE
PRESS ONE BEEN VERO NOW AGAIN
TO UPHOLD PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE NOW. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
IN THE QUEUE AT THE MOMENT. ALL
RIGHT LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS ANYONE OF
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS CENTER
LEYVA MOVE THE BILL THANK YOU
CENTER LEYVA ALL RIGHT- CONSOLE
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED MOTION
IS TO PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG ACT
NUMBER I NIELSEN L. NIELSEN NO
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG AYE LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE STERN. STERN ON
BILLS OUT FOR TWO ONE. THANK
YOU CENTER NIELSEN ARE YOU
CENTERS FOR YOU WAITING. WHAT
WILL WE WILL MORE BUILT. SEN
NELSON WE.
SIR ROBERT HAVE ONE
MORE BILL THAT CRIME BILL STATE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU
SENATE BILL FOUR TWENTY THREE
BY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AND
MYSELF OF THE NOVEMBER ELECTION
IS LESS THAN FOUR MONTHS AWAY
YET WE STILL CANNOT SAY WITH
CERTAINTY HOW COVERT NINETEEN
WILL BE AFFECTED US AT THAT
TIME. THANKS TO I'M AND BERMAN
AB EIGHT SIXTY HOWEVER EVERY
REGISTERED VOTER IN CALIFORNIA
WILL RECEIVE A BALLOT IN THE
MAIL. RIGHT PROVIDING A SAFE
ALTERNATIVE TO VOTING IN PERSON.
ANY CALIFORNIA. CANNOT OR
CHOOSE TO USE THEIR VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOT FOR INSTANCE IF
YOU- IF YOU NEED TO USE
ACCESSIBLE FOR. WOMEN IF YOU
HAVE SOME REASON TO. HAVE TO.
PERSON I'M SORT OF CHECK ENGINE
LIGHT YOU MAY WANNA VOTE IN
PERSON HOMELESS FOLKS. MAY NOT
RECEIVE A MAIL IN BALLOT-
BALLOTS MAY BE DAMAGE OR EVEN
OCCASIONALLY- MISPLACED THOSE
FOLKS MAY WANT TO GO TO THE
POLLING PLACE AND VOTE PERSON.
SB FOUR TWENTY THREE GUARANTEES
THAT ACCESSIBLE SIX IN STATE IN
PERSON ATTORNEYS. FOR ALL
VOTERS OF FOUR FULL FOUR FULL
DAYS STARTING THE SET A PRIOR
TO THE ELECTION. SB FOUR TWENTY
THREE WILL ALSO REQUIRE
NUMEROUS CONVENIENT LOCATIONS
WERE VOTERS WHO SIMPLY WANT TO
DROP OFF THE BALLOTS. AS WELL
AS A STATEWIDE BOOK EDUCATE I
READ CAMPAIGN IN REGARD THOSE
PROCEDURES. KEEP IN MIND RISEN
DOOR. FOR THE OF THE COUNTY
WOULD RATHER THERE LIKE IS THE
PRE. WHETHER THEY ARE VOTER
CHOICE COUNTY OR TRADITIONAL
POLLING PLACE COUNTY THEY'RE
FREE TO DO SO. EITHER WAY THEY
MUST STILL SEND EVERY
REGISTERED. VOTER ABOUT AT FOUR
TWENTY THREE WILL ENSURE AMPLE
IN EARLY IN PERSON VOTING
OPPORTUNITY IS IN A MANNER THAT
IS CONSISTENT WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDANCE. REQUIREMENTS
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY RECOGNIZE
THE COUNTIES MAY FACE COVERT
NINETEEN DELETED CHALLENGES.
WHEN IT COMES PROVIDING. WILL
SET. THEY WILL BE HAVE
ELECTIONS WHETHER IT'S A VOTE
CENTER. COUNTY OR NON THAT ARE
CHARACTERS COUNTIES WILL HAVE
TO PROVIDE AT LEAST ONE VOTING
LOCATION FOR EVERY TEN THOUSAND
REGISTERED VOTERS. APPLE
LOCATION VERY FIFTEENTH STREET
VOTERS. CAN IS WISHING TO
PARTICIPATE WHO MAKE A VALID
EFFORT TO COMPLY WILL BE ABLE
TO SEEK. PARTIAL WAIVERS AND
SECTORS STATE IF THEY'RE ON A
TO. A HUNDRED PER OF THE RIVER.
BOATING SO OR DRAW OFF OKAY. AS
WE ALREADY SEEN IN THE STATE'S
A MASSIVE REDUCTION VOTING
LOCATION. WHAT WAS THE LAW THE
LINE IN LARGE. AND PUT TO
UNSAFE GATHERING ON ELECTION
DAY. AS BEFORE TWELFTH WILL.
THAT WILL NOT BE THE CASE IN
CALIFORNIA IS USUALLY
COMMITTEES ANNOUNCES DOES NOT
IN AND OF EXT ALL THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS. AND BACKGROUND. OF
AND FURTHER INTO THE TILT FOR.
OF THE STATE WORKING SO CLOSELY
ON THIS SB FOUR. TWENTY THREE
SUPPORT ABOUT THE SECTORS STATE
THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE AS WELL AS- OTHER CIVIC
ORGANIZATION I URGE AN AYE
VOTE. MISS MOCK I THINK IS
STILL ON THE PHONE AND SHE WILL
BE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE PROCEED MISS MOCK. THANK
YOU KAREN MEMBERS ONCE AGAIN-
KIDNEY MOCK AT PT SECRETARY
GAVE FOR LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF SECRETARY ALEX YEAH
WE URGE OUR I'VE DAY TO MAKE
SURE VOTERS HAVE A SAFE WAY TO
VOTE IN THE NOVEMBER GENERAL
ELECTION CONSIDERING THE
COLLUDED NINETEEN AND THEN I.
EARLIER IS A- TURNED IT TO THE
HER LAWS IN PLACE. COUNTY YOU
ARE SEEKING AND ALTERNATE THE
BALANCE THERE NEED TO MAKE
EVERYONE IS SAFE AND HEALTHY
AND ABLE TO VOTE FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ORDER AYE VOTE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF FORMALLY. SE NON
HERE IN THE CHAMBER I SEE NO
ONE STANDING UP IN REQUESTING.
THE TESTIFIED AND LET'S GO TO
TWENTY FORTY AND THAT ROOM
APPEARS TO BE VACANT AS WELL.
THAT WOULD LEAD ME TO BELIEVE
THERE IS NO ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY. IN FAVOR OF SAN
ROMBERG ARE YOU AWARE OF ANYONE
ELSE THAT WE SHOULD. REQUEST
THE TECH. I AM NOT AND THAT
SAID THEN WOULD LOOK LET'S
REPEAT REPEAT NOW TO THE
OPPOSITION. ANYONE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBER HERE IS TO POST
THE BILL. PARDON. LET'S GO NOW
TO THE PHONE LINES A MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD BE SO KIND. AS TO.
THOSE WHO MAY BE ON THE LINE.
IT WAS A NUMBER OF THOSE WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION.
SUPPORT MAKE SCREENING CHANNEL
IN SUPPORT OF THIS WOULD BE
TESTABLE DANCEABLE. GOT IT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE DAY AND THEIR OWN NOW
IN THE SHOW OF SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN. AND WE HAVE
WELL I'M A LINE LOCAL LINE.
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MELISSA ROMERO WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN THE
COURT. WELL NOT GO TO LINE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE CALL I HAD. HI
EVERYONE I'M REMOVING A
CALIFORNIA STATE DIRECTOR OF MI
FAMILIA BOCA AND FULL SUPPORT.
HELLO TO LINE FIFTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
NUMBERS AARON RODRIGUEZ FOR THE
UNION O CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
IN STRONG SUPPORT. MAX THE LAW
TO LINE FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI EVERYONE THE OF THE
IT'S IN YOUR FROM THE LEGAL
LIMóN VOTERS CALIFORNIA
CALLING FOR THANK YOU. NOT
TRYING SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON ERIN
SEVEN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
NARAL PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND THAT
FILL THE TIMELINE FIFTY YEARS
AGO I HAD. AFTERNOON KNOW OUR
TO ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. AND
ACCESSIBLE TIMELINE SEVENTY
EIGHT FORYOUR CALL I HAD. BY
THE RIGHT ORDER REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE IN
SUPPORT. I HAD VERY MINOR IF
YOU WISH TO STILL SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS THE ONE THEN THEIR
OWN NOW AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THEIR OWN
NOW. THEN WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MODERATOR DO A-
REQUEST ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. AND YOUR
Q. AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO UPHOLD PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN THERE- NOW AGAIN IT TO
OPPOSE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE NOW. WE HAVE A NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE AT THE MOMENT. THANK
YOU IN A MEMBERS HERE PRESENT
WISH TO ASK ANY QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE DO WE HAVE A MOTION
MOVE THE BILL. MOVED BY CENTER
GAVE A- AND YOU MAY CLOSE IF
YOU LIKE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR ASSEMBLY WITH THANK YOU
YOUR FOUR FOUR FOUR REGIONAL
VOTE. ALL RIGHT PERFECT TABLE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATE
BILL FOR TWENTY THREE MOTIONS
AT THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRED IN HAMBURG. BURKE HI
NIELSEN NO NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE STERN STERN AYE STERN ON.
THE BILL IS A FOUR TO ONE.
FORTY ONE BILL AS FAST. THERE
NIELSEN MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE
TESTIFIED TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING THE ELECTIONS A
CONSTITUTIONAL MEMBERS
COMMITTEE VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT YOUR
TESTIMONY OFFICIAL HEARING
RECORDS THANK YOU AND
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
THANK EVER FOR PATIENCE AND
COOPER WE HAVE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA THIS COME ON. BECAUSE
MOVEMENTS